good morning John it's Friday I'm going
to be talking about sidewalks for this
entire video but if you bear with me I
know that it doesn't seem like it but it
will be worth it four years ago I didn't
have an idea for the video that I wanted
to make so I asked Twitter to send me
ideas one of the things that was until I
was told to do by shiny Joseph was to
interview the sidewalk so I did that I'm
here today with a sidewalk to talk about
what it's like to be a sidewalk so
sidewalk what do you think well I got no
complaints except tree roots don't get
me started on tree roots fascinating I
also did this dance which that's good
there's a link if you want to watch that
2013 vlogbrothers video ever since I
made that video I have spent surprising
amount of time thinking about
interviewing sidewalks where we grew up
in Florida sidewalks were boring and
consistent than they were all they done
at the same time here in Missoula
sidewalks were laid down a hundred years
ago they were laid down last Tuesday so
it's like a weird patchwork and a lot of
them are falling apart and also they
have occasionally you'll see makers
marks that will tell you who laid the
sidewalk and what year it was laid down
maker's marks are part advertisement
part like record-keeping so the city
knows who did what and part warranty so
I like if it breaks you know who did it
after the 50s these kind of go away and
so you are more reliant on people
actually carving like just illicitly
carving the year into this sidewalk
which I actually appreciate though not
legal technically if you look hard
enough you could see that sidewalks look
different from different eras both
because of how they've weathered and
also the materials that were used in
them well it's a thing that I think
about which is why recently I was
outside of a friend of Mines house and I
had a moment it would like a rather
intense sidewalk related moment
sometimes in sidewalks you will see
footprints like people footprints or dog
footprints so I was seeing that there
were these little people footprints they
looked like they were probably from a
kid like two or three years old just
like a kid wandered onto the wet cement
just look definitely sidewalk for a
little while I was following those
footsteps I got to a makers mark where
it said miracle and trip of the maker
1909 and as a person who thinks a lot
about sidewalks my
the math I actually did some research on
this it was Frank miracle and Henry trip
where the the guys who laid that
Sidewalk in 1909 and actually had a
guarantee for five years after they were
the sidewalk if anything went wrong they
would replace it and here it is it's a
hundred then nine years later and Frank
miracle isn't around anymore
Henry trip isn't it around anymore and
that little kid who made those footsteps
assumably grew up lived a life and is
also gone you might be thinking Oh Hank
is sad because he has a baby and baby
grew up and lived and but it's actually
kind of a thing that I like um I like I
don't have context to that person's life
but what I do have is knowledge that
they were there like that moment when
the sidewalk was laid down this this
thing happened this tiny insignificant
little human thing I like when people
create things with the the knowledge and
the intent that they're gonna be around
serving a purpose after those people are
gone
but here's the real thing I like that
this inanimate chunk of concrete
connects people who don't know that
they're connected and I don't think that
we're ever very good at understanding
how connected we are to each other
to the whole sort of system of the earth
like people take drugs to feel that
feeling and I got it from a sidewalk
that feeling of being part of something
that existed long before us stretches
out way beyond us is very neat it's very
good it's very real it's very big and I
like it and that's my sidewalk story
John I'll see you on Tuesday
oh hey kitty hi you you surprised me